bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filcho on commence tout de suite avec
les grandes lignes de cette émission le
premier centre mondial de recherche et
développement dédié à la route nous a
ouvert ses portes à manilamo découverte
des innovations en termees de
construction et
d'entretien
56500 c'est le nombre de chômeurs
rivelinois au mois d'août soit 2,6 % de
moins qu'en
juillet plus de 6000 personnes ont
obtenu la reconnaissance de travailleurs
handicapés dans le département l'année
dernière quelle solution pour s'insérer
dans le monde professionnel réponse dans
le dossier de la semaine et puis nous
nous aborderons pardon également le
développement du tourisme dans les
Yvelines le conseiller général vient de
lancer l'ybx un confret comprenant 78
offres de loisirs et d'hébergement
une initiative qui s'inscrit dans une
politique plus large d'attractivité du
territoire nous ferons le point avec
notre invité Sylvie laouna bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes donc la directrice
divlin tourisme c'est ça on vous
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
faire un point avant cela on passe tout
de suite à l'actualité économique de la
semaine alors on en parlait à l'instant
le lancement de l'Î gregbx était célébré
ce mardi à l'intérieur des réductions
pour des loisirs ou des hébergements
dans le département un concept original
que je vous propose de découvrir dans ce
reportage réalisé avec Patrick Jacques
de
Dixmude l'ybx est disponible dans le
commerce depuis mardi un coffret qui
regroupe 78 offres culturelles de
loisirs ou d'hébergement à prix bradé
moin 50 %. nuit d'hôtel visite de musées
ou encore paintball il s'agissait de de
partir d'une réflexion très simple qui
était de dire aujourd'hui les gens
partent moins loin moins longtemps en
vacances proposonsleur de redécouvrir ou
de découvrir tout simplement les
evelines l'entreprise smart and Co est
habituée au box en tout genre mais l'ybx
est son premier partenariat avec une
collectivité l'initiative vient en effet
du conseil général qui espère booster le
secteur du tourisme on a fait le calcul
à peu près si les acheteurs les futurs
acheteurs de cette iBox utilisent tout
ce qui leur est offert ils font une
économie de 3000 € donc vous voyez pour
un investissement de moins de 30 € c'est
une un bon placement mais au-delà de ça
c'est bien entendu destiné à mieux faire
connaître les ivelines dans le
département le tourisme reste en effet
peu développé à l'exception du site du
château de Versailles ce projet de box
est dans les cartons depuis un an et
demi il a fallu dans un premier temps
convaincre les partenaires les hôtels
qui assurent principalement une
clientèle d'affaires en semaine y on vu
un moyen de combler leur faible taux
d'occupation du weekend en moyenne moins
de 50 %. c'est une façon de bloquer dans
les ivelin nos nos clients potentiels et
essayer de siffonner un peu Paris qui
qui atti vraiment trop par rapport à
nous leurs offres ne sont disponibles
que le weekend toutes les activités du
coffret peuvent être utilisé une fois
dans la limite d'un
an les chiffres du chômage sont tombés
cette semaine dans les ivelines on
compte 2,6 % de chômeurs en moins la
courbe s'inverse enfin après 24 mois
d'augmentation cette nouvelle est
valable pour la France également 1,5 %
de chômeurs en moins à noter tout de
même le grand nombre de résiliation
auprès de Pôle emploi vous ne savez
peut-être pas mais le plus grand centre
mondial de recherche dédié à la route se
situe à Saint-Quentin en iveline il
s'agit du campus scientifique et
technique de l'entreprise Colas nous
nous sommes rendus ce jeudi à ses portes
ouvertes un reportage réalisé avec
Elodie
moan le campus scientifique et technique
de Colas le CST est le premier centre
mondial de recherche et développement
privé dédié à la route il est installé à
maniléamo et ce jeudi il ouvrait ses
portes c'est une première parce qu'on a
conduit depuis 2 ans des travaux de
restructuration sur le site des travaux
de développement de certains outils on
arrive à l'aboutissement de l'ensemble
de ces travaux et il semblait légitime
de faire connaître au collaborateurs du
Groupe d'une part mais également à nos
clients les nouveaux outils dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui sur le site du de
manilamo l'entreprise Colas spécialisée
dans la construction et l'entretien des
routes s'attache à trouver de nouvelles
techniques ou de nouveaux matériaux pour
augmenter la performance ou encore
l'emprunte éc
dans ce laboratoire Flavien teste
l'adhérence des chaussées cette machine
permet de vieillir les échantillons ces
recherches ont permis de créer un enrobé
plus performant
l'optigripe on va être sur des des taux
accidentogènes qui sont divisés par
10 avec des produits très sécuritaires
ici on a trouvé le moyen d'augmenter la
rétroréflexion des revêtements au sol la
bande CST est plus visible son secret
elle est spoudrée de bille de verre qui
réfléchissent la lumière autre thème de
recherche l'étude de l'usure des routes
ce prototype permet de retranscrire
l'état de la route et les fissures
éventuell grâce à des lasers projetés
sur le sol la vitesse d'acquisition est
de 80 km/h pour une résolution des
images de 1 mm donc ça nous permet
d'avoir un très très haut rendement au
point de vue auscultation des
chaussées après traitement des image on
peut anticiper les travaux de rénovation
à moyen terme dans cet autre laboratoire
Sébastien cherche à limiter le bruit de
roulement et donc les nuisances sonores
il cherche le meilleur matériau pour
améliorer le
coefficient soit réfléchissante pour le
bonifier on a différents outils ces
outils sont là pour optimiser notre
formule et si vous voulez c'est comme
une recette de cuisine on va jouer avec
nos ingrédients jouer sur les
différentes proportions on va aussi par
exemple jouer sur la taille des granulas
sur le
diamètre étonnamment entre ces deux
enrobés c'est celui de droite qui limite
le plus le bruit h fois moins qu'un
orobé classique la société colass
présente sur les cinq continents se
charge de 100000 chantiers dans le monde
son chiffre d'affaires s'élève à 13
milliards d'euros vous pour
imaginer les emplois francs s'ouvrent à
un plus grand nombre d'agglomérations en
France dont c-quenttin en Yveline alors
bon con son les emplois francs c'est une
mesure visant à favoriser l'accès à
l'emploi des jeunes des quartiers
difficiles ils ont été lancés en juill
dernier il donne droit à une prime de
5000 € aux entreprises qui leur
proposent un CDI à temps plein
l'objectif à atteindre 5000 emploi d'ici
2014 ces contrats ne concernaient
jusqu'ici que 10 communes
françaises les salariés de la société
Amundi qui ont dû quitter leurs locaux
de la Tour Montparnasse en raison de
présence d'amiante ont été relocalisés à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline nous avons
contactter l'entreprise qui nous a
indiqué qu'elle cherchait actuellement
des possibilités de rapprochement avec
leur
site pour les auto-entrepreneurs et
travailleurs indépendants bbre se veut
plus qu'un bureau partagé découverte des
lieux en images avec Patrick Jacques
dixmud journée portes ouvertes vendredi
dernier dans ce nouvel espace de
coworking réservé aux travailleurs
indépendants les entrepreneurs pourront
travailler dans cet open space un lieu
qui se veut convivial pour former à
terme une vraie
communauté ouvrir ses bureaux c'est un
petit peu ce qui manque quand on est
indépendant c'est de pouvoir échanger
avec les autres les autres corps de
métier pouvoir créer du du réseau et je
trouve que le concept est intéressant
pour ça quoi ici les abonnés afficheront
leur profil pour faciliter l'utilisation
du réseau de coworkers 12 personnes
peuvent travailler dans cet openpace
connecté à un réseau Wii et équipé d'une
imprimante pas de bureau dédié bibre
souhaite se démarquer des télécentres
classiques trois salles de réunion de 4
à 10 personnes peuvent être louées déjà
je je travaille donc chez moi je n'ai
pas de salle pour recevoir des clients
je n'ai pas de salle pour faire des
réunions ou des formations des petites
formations d'une journée ou une
demi-journée pour de la sensibilisation
donc c'est intéressant ce genre de
d'espace est intéressant pour moi cet
espace veut s'adapter aux besoins variés
des travailleurs indépendants accès
ponctuel compter 20 € pour un accès
d'une demi-journée ou illimité 900 €
pour un trimestre 5tin en ieline il y a
à peu près 1400 entreprises
indépendantes des auto-entrepreneurs des
TPE des PME donc il y a un potentiel
énorme il y a une forte demande et
j'espère que cet espace sera un succès
et cet espace sera fréquenté par ces
personnes des ateliers pratiques seront
organisés prochainement l'ouverture est
prévue le 1er
octobre un service d'aide médico-social
pour les adultes handicapés a été
inauguré hier à plaisir il propose des
accompagnement multidisciplinaire comme
l'accès à l'emploi la directrice nous
raconte le parcours réussi d'un jeune 3
handicapé mental le métier auquel il est
il s'exerce en fait c'est être
finalement agent administratif donc
voyez-vous c'est un jeune qu'on
accompagne depuis maintenant 2 3 ans
voilà on a commencé par écouter évaluer
et puis orienter donc au jour
d'aujourd'hui on est en train vraiment
de presque on est dans une je dirais
niveau d'aboutissement de son projet
hein et c'est en soi une satisfaction
pour l'équipe hein je pense mais aussi
et surtout pour ce jeune homme qui ne
croyait pas du tout en lui voilà et nous
aurons l'occasion d'aborder ce thème de
l'emploi et du handicap dans le dossier
de la semaine on passe maintenant à
l'entretien alors cette année le Conseil
général met clairement l'accent sur le
développement du tourisme de nombreuses
actions ont été mise en place
dernièrement et on en parlait tout à
l'heure le lancement de l'ybx le budget
divine tourisme a également été doublé
de 1 à 2 millions donc Sylvie launa vous
êtes justement la directrice divivine
tourisme on va un petit peu détailler ce
qui a permis cette hausse de budget euh
par exemple vous proposez maintenant
trois événements dans l'année PZ nous en
dire plus oui nous sommes organisateur
d'événementiel effectivement pour
convaincre les habitants des Yvelines
qu'ils ont un cadre de vie exceptionnel
et puis faire venir les Franciliens dans
les Yvelines parce que c'est un un cadre
de loisirs qui est Fab avec plein de
choses à voir et on est quand même le
poumon vert de l'île-de-fance alors il y
a eu vers les ivelines oui parole de
jardinier cet été encore actuellement
d'ailleurs et puis il y en a un
troisième à venir c'est ça donc
effectivement l'idée c'est de
proposer à nos clients potentiels des
événements qui représentent un un un
type de loisir qui les concerne
particulièrement puisque ce sont des
pratiques de loisirs particulièrement
important en France donc la randonnée
pour vers les Yvelines le jardinage pour
paroolle de jardinier et la cuisine la
gastronomie pour goodû d'iveline qui est
donc le futur événement que nous
organiserons du 17 novembre au 1er
décembre un événement culinaire cette
fois c'est ça alors pour chacun de ces
sites un site internet a été créé et
vous nêtes pas arrêté à ça vous avez
également créé un site de réservation
d'hébergement un site de sortie et c'est
pas fini et c'est pas fini donc le
site S
t-eveline.fr propose des idées de sortie
donc pour les ivelinois les Franciliens
ou même ceux qui sont en séjour de dans
le département donc on a plein de choses
plein d'idées pour pour s'occuper
pendant ces loisirs pendant ces weekends
et
puis le site weekend qui sort le 15
octobre effectivement propose des
séjours pour augmenter les retombées
économiques sur le territoire et puis
favoriser le développement des de ce
qu'on appelle les taux d'occupation dans
l'hôtellerie et le dernier avenir qui
sort le 9 décembre prochain à la fin de
l'année et destiné à valoriser tout ce
qui est loisir
nature la randonnée les bases de loisirs
avec les activités nautique les golfs
enfin tout ce qu'il y a à faire en plein
air et avec ces sites finalement vous
ouvrez un autre public les événements
étaient particulièrement destinés aux
ivelinois là vous essayez d'attirer
également des touristes étrangers
peut-être oui sur le site weekend qui
sort le 15 octobre effectivement il est
destiné à à cibler un public français et
étranger de proximité comme les
néerlandais les Anglais les Belges qui
ont déjà goûté entre guillemets à Paris
qui sont devenus déjà plusieurs fois ce
que nous on appelle dans notre jargon
les repeaters qui sont venus plusieurs
fois donc et qui ont envie de voir un
petit peu ce qu'il y a autour de Paris
et donc forcément les Yvelines ils ont
déjà un peu goûté puisqu'ils sont venus
à Versailles et effectivement ils vont
venir en séjour donc on leur propose des
hôtels de charme pour les amoureux pour
euh des une famille qui pourrait venir
aussi en pleine nature passer un bon
moment c'est également en fait l'objet
de de l'y box on l'entendait dans dans
le sujet le le président des clubs des
hôteliier expliquer que la semaine le
taux d'occupation des hôtels à voisine
les 95 % c'est une clientèle d'affaires
par contre c'est difficile d'atteindre
les 50 % le weekend c'est ça finalement
le but avec ces différents sites ces
différents événements c'est aussi
finalement de de d'accueillir plus de
personnes en weekend en visite
touristique alors le but l'objectif
quand on est directrice d'une structure
comme la mienne Yveline tourisme c'est
d'augmenter les retombées économiques
sur le territoire on est dans filco donc
on ne peut pas se passer dans d'en
parler effectivement quand on développe
les taux d'occupation des établissements
hôteliers le weekend on augmente
l'activité économique et donc
effectivement la ybx dont vous parliez
elle propose 28
hébergements à tarif réduit c'est-à-dire
que si on consomme une nuit on a une
nuit offerte qui n'est pas négligeable
même certains établissements haut de
gamme 4 étoiles sont sont dans cette box
et donc donc ça propose une une économie
considérable pour le visiteur mais une
économie accrue sur le département alors
vous êtes également développé beaucoup
sur les réseaux sociaux des des vidéos
sur YouTube vous avez notamment investi
dans dans des films promotionnels et
puis également Alice des ivelines qui
qui est assez active sur la page
facebook oui du coup vous avez grossi
vos équipes vous avez choisi
d'externaliser pour les films comment ça
s'est passé un petit peu ce changement
alors effectiv c'est un gros changement
puisque le métier que nous faisons tous
Actuellement est différent de celui que
nous faisions il y a un an donc on
externalise évidemment puisque cette
nouvelle stratégie d'attractivité du
territoire a été mise en place avec la
même équipe que par le passé donc cette
même équipe il a fallu qu'elle change de
métier comme je vous le disais qu'elle
fasse des formations donc on a tous eu
des formations sur écrire sur le web
pour être meilleur pour donner envie sur
nos sites Web de de venir sur le
territoire et puis puis des formations
plus techniques sur sur les sites Web et
puis donc de ce fait comme l'équipe n'a
pas changé on peut pas devenir
professionnel de la vidéo ni de la photo
donc on externalise certaines choses
effectivement très bien merci beaucoup
en tout cas CV la d'être d'avoir été
présente sur notre plateau et puis on
verra du coup d'ici quelques mois si si
ça a fonctionné oui espéronsle on passe
maintenant au dossier de la
semaine
on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'intégration professionnelle des
personnes handicapées je vous propose de
découvrir plus en détail ce qui est mise
en place pour eux entreprise classique
ou spécialisé structure d'erde et
d'accompagnement un système qui englobe
des réalités très différentes d'un
handicap à l'autre un sujet réalisé avec
elodim moine Jacques Patrick Jacques de
dixm pardon et Jonathan Vman en 2012
6400 personnes ont été reconnues
travailler handicapé dans les ivelines
pour eux crise économique ou non trouver
un emploi relève souvent de la bataille
le taux de chômage attend 20 % le double
de la moyenne nationale la loi française
impose aux entreprises de plus de 20
salariés de comptabiliser 6 % de
personnes handicapées dans leur effectif
bien souvent les entreprises préfèrent
payer des pénalités nantonin fait partie
du million et demi de malvoyant en
France depuis 4 ans et demi elle
travaille à malakov meric comme chargée
de recrutement et des mobilités un
parcours qu'elle n'aurait jamais imaginé
car nantonin a commencé sa carrière dans
le sport petite elle s'imaginait
professeur de PS son sport de
prédilection l'athlétisme elle remporte
en 2008 la médaille d'argent en 400 m
aux Jeux Olympiques quelques mois plus
tard malakov Méric cherche à recruter
des athlètes de haut niveau handicapés
nantonin répond présente je suis pas du
tout là pour recruter d'autres personnes
en situation d'handicap il pas d'autres
sportif c'est vraiment je suis enfin
demander à mes collègues mais je suis
une collaboratrice lambda je suis sur
mon périmètre comme au même titre que
mes autres collègues enfin il y a
vraiment rien de différent qu à part que
oui j'ai un petit souci de vu mais voilà
nantonin a vu son poste aménager comme
par exemple l'attribution d'un écran
plus grand 21 pouces l'écriture a grandi
forcément parce que l'écran est plus
grand mais en fait au départ j'avais
demandé le zoom texte que j'ai arrêté
par la suite zoomtex donc qui agrandit
les caractères en fait j'ai arrêté parce
que ça me déstabilisait complètement et
ça me ralentissait dans mon travail euh
parce que tout n'était pas sur l'écran
et qu'il fallait à chaque fois jongler
avec les curseurs donc j'ai arrêté c'est
pour ça je suis très près de mon écran
si elle apprécie l'accueil qu'on lui a
réservé nantonin sait bien qu'elle a
trouvé une entreprise modèle avant
d'intégrer ce poste elle a postulé dans
une banque et la réaction était tout
autre on m'a dit clairement votre profil
est très très très bien et vous
comprenez on peut pas vous mettre face à
la clientèle je à bon euh oui mais par
rapport au handicap on sait pas comment
les clients vont réagir depuis 2005 la
loi handicap a introduit un droit à
compensation la collectivité doit lui
apporter les moyens de compenser son
handicap notamment face à l'emploi une
des missions de la Maison départementale
des personnes
handicapées nous voici à la Maison
Départementale des Personnes handicapé
la MDPH elle est chargée de l'accueil et
de l'accompagnement des ivinois
handicapés et elle les aiguilles dans
leur parcours
professionnel Laurence marin bonjour
bonjour vous êtes ici la référente
insertion professionnelle justement vous
votre rôle c'est de les conseiller de
leur proposer des aides de les aiguiller
vers la bonne entreprise alors d'évaluer
leurs demandes et de les orienter vers
les bons dispositifs d'accompagnement
alors si une personne est en recherche
d'emploi elle sera orientée vers les
services publics de l'emploi c'estàdire
Pôle emploi ou vers Cap Emploi qui qui
est l'opérateur dédié à leur
accompagnement si elles sont sont en
poste dans ce cas le médecin du travail
les services d'appui au maintien dans
l'emploi des travailleurs handicapés
pourront intervenir les missions
handicap des entreprises pour aménager
leurs postees de travail donc vous
n'avez pas de lien finalement avec les
entreprises elles-mêmes ça m'arrive très
régulièrement ne serait-ce que pour
répondre aux questions des salariés
informer sur les droits informer sur la
les modalités à suivre pour pour
demander une reconnaissance de la
qualité de travailleur handicapé
répondre à beaucoup de questions parce
que ça fait encore très peur à la fois
au salariés et à l'entreprise 6400
personnes ont obtenu la reconnaissance
travailleurs handicapés en 2012 environ
15 % de ces personnes relèvent du milieu
protégés c'est-à-dire vont travailler au
sein d'un nat et les 85 % restants
relèvent du milieu ordinaire de travail
donc des entreprises du secteur privé ou
du secteur public alors à quelle
difficulté ces personnes ont à faire
face au niveau de l'emploi alors souvent
une réadaptation puisqueen fait la santé
les empêche d'exercer le métier qu'elles
ont exercé longtemps ce qui entraîne une
formation une remise en question
personnelle à de nouvelles compétences à
acquérir et puis convaincre un employeur
que à 45 ans on est débutant dans un
métier et qu'on est tout à fait
opérationnel et aussi de pouvoir rendre
compatible la situation de handicap avec
le poste de travail pour conclure
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être amélioré
finalement dans dans ce domaine une
meilleure connaissance du handicap parce
qu'en fait dans une quand on parle
handicap ça revet énormément de
situations différentes des situations
peuvent nous sembler est difficile à
vivre alors que certaines personnes vont
tout à fait être opérationnelles au
travail même si de Prim à bord le
handicap nous semble important donc
c'est vraiment comprendre que ça revit
une situation vraiment des situations
différentes et complexes mais surtout
que chez cette population la capacité au
travail est très présente et peut tout à
fait entrer dans une organisation
entreprise à la condition qu'elle soit
relativement souple très bien merci
beaucoup
quand le handicap est trop lourd la MDPH
dirige les personnes vers un
NAT de madeg bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur de cette esad alors
finalement à quoi sert-t-il ça permet
d'intégrer professionnellement des
personnes handicapées alors lesad comme
son n l'indique c'est un établissement
de soutien et d'aide par le travail ici
là on accueille 145 personnes hommes et
femmes de plus de 20 ans donc il nous
sommes orientés par la MDPH la Maison
Départementale de handicap donc c'est
des personnes qui ne peuvent pas
travailler plus de un tiers temps par
rapport à une personne valide donc notre
public est constitué essentiellement de
personnes handicapé mental et des
handicapés psychiques voire des malades
psychiques ce qui complexifie un petit
peu la la situation parfois au niveau du
travail ce côtoi donc ici des personnes
au handicap très varié à 31 ans Amélie n
travaillé que dans des structures de ce
type mais elle se plaît dans la
blanchisserie c'est je faire métier
Joseline a quant à elle intégré ce
service il y a seulement 2 ans je suis
épileptique alors je peux plus rester
dans le normal voilà ça me plaît
beaucoup ici je suis presque à la
retraite hein dans 2 ans 2 ans et demi
donc c'est
Z pour ces personnes au profil variés un
accompagnement est mise en place 37
salariés les encadrent moniteur
d'atelier psychologue ou encore
administratif et les ates s'appuient sur
des partenaires extérieur des centres
médicaux au centre d'hébergement en
dehors de la blanchisserie lesat s'est
spécialisé dans la soup les espaces
verts et la décoration végétale et la
restauration qui sont vos clients
finalement alors les clients nous avons
pas loin de 300 clients qui sont situés
essentiellement sur l'Î de France nous
avons de petits clients jusqu'au gross
entreprises multinationales comme talè
EADS BG après avoir perdu un client
lesat a enregistré une perte sèche de
800000 € par an pour rester
concurrentiel la blanchisserie a été
agrandie et mod is le volume de linge
devrait passer de 200 kg à 600 kg voire
une tonne et demi par jour etésat n'est
pas que concurrentiel il a un atout
économique important pour les
entreprises ne respectant pas le quota
des 6 % de travailleurs handicapés faire
affaire avec un ESAT leur permet de voir
leur pénalité divisé par de un système
gagnant gagnant un gain économique et
l'emploi de travailleurs qui
s'intégrerai difficilement dans une
entreprise non adaptée les personnes
restent quand même des personnes
imprévisibles donc ils peuvent lâcher à
tout moment euh les arrêts maladies on
ne les compte plus les absences non
justifié c'est idem l'attention
particulière elle est donnée aussi au
rythme de travail aux capacités de
personnes à ce qu'il peut produire au
niveau des ateliers comme vous
l'indiquer c'est c'est compliqué
finalement pour ces personnes d'être
inséré dans un dans une entreprise
classique VO tout à fait tout à fait ça
reste assez minime euh le pourcentage
national d'ailleurs et la voisine même
pas le 0 1 % puisque c'est des handicaps
assez lourds et qui nécessitent un
accompagnement de la part des
entreprises peu d'intégration dans le
monde professionnel classique mais Yvin
a une motivation bien à lui parce que
c'est différent du milieu ordinaire la
paye elle est moins grosse voilà surtout
ça pour beaucoup ces zat restent tout de
même le seul employeur adapté à trrappe
l'établissement est plein et compte de
80 à 100 personnes chaque année sur la
liste d'attentees d'après un sondage
réalisé auprès de 60 entreprises
cinquantinoises la part de travailleurs
handicapés atteint péniblement les 3,5 %
et seulement 48 % des salariés
interrogés estiment que leur entreprise
a mis en place des actions visant à
l'accès ou au maintien des personnes
handicapées et à noter la 3e semaine de
novembre marque la Semaine de l'emploi
et du handicap des événements de
sensibilisation et un forum emploi sera
organisé dans le département c'est la
fin de ce filcho merci d'avoir été avec
nous je vous donne rendez-vous jeudi
prochain pour un prochain filcho bonne
soirée